[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: What's the
difference between
a globally-distributed database
with strong consistency and one
without?
Predictability.
No missing data, no
out-of-sync data,
reliable accuracy every time.
With Google Cloud Spanner,
the horizontally-scalable
relational database, your data
is available when it's needed.
And it's consistent no
matter where your users are.
It's a predictability
that you can depend on.
With other databases offering
less-than-strong consistency,
your data may or
may not be there
when your users need
it most, or even worse,
it may not be accurate.
Google Cloud Spanner gives
you all of the benefits
of a relational database--
simplicity, speed,
and data integrity--
while scaling to handle
even the most challenging
of transactional workloads.
Google Cloud Spanner.
Never choose between scale
and data accuracy again.